are you aware of the biggest scam in
Internet history you meet someone on a
dating app or social media platform
they're sweet and complimentary maybe a
little shy because they're not quite
ready to meet up yet but then after a
few weeks the topic turns to
cryptocurrency crypto romance schemes
have stolen more money than perhaps any
other internet scam potentially over a
billion dollars in 2022 alone they
originated in China and Southeast Asia
where they are known as Pig butchering
because the victim is fattened up with
flattery before the slaughter once trust
is established the scammer will
recommend crypto as a lucrative
investment and offer to help you set up
a crypto wallet they encourage you to
invest your cryptocurrency at a site
that looks legit but is actually
controlled by the scammer they'll even
let you withdraw little amounts to make
it seem on the level then when you've
invested enough suddenly you're locked
out of your account and your new boo
goes you because cryptocurrency is
anonymous and unregulated it's virtually
impossible to get that money back